y varios barcos y aviones de guerra
chinos han continuado operando esta
mañana en las cercanías de la línea
media la frontera marítima oficiosa pero
podrían ser los últimos así al menos lo
sugiere un comunicado del alto mando
militar chino que parece que da por
concluidas las maniobras asegura que el
ejército ya ha completado con éxito las
misiones previstas y probado la eficacia
de las tropas así que a partir de ahora
se limitará a observar la situación del
estrecho con patrullas regulares las
maniobras las mayores en la historia del
hecho fueron la respuesta a la visita de
la congresista nancy pelosi aunque china
había anunciado que terminaría en el
domingo se han acabado alargando tres
días más el anuncio llega el mismo día
en el que pekín ha desvelado su nuevo
libro blanco sobre taiwán dibuja dos
escenarios opuestos uno con un amplio
espacio pacífico para la reunificación
en el que taiwán disfrutará de una gran
seguridad y dignidad bajo el paraguas de
china y el otro en cambio de una gran
hostilidad y de 'tolerancia cero' no
sólo a las actividades separatistas en
la isla sino a las fuerzas extranjeras
que cruzan las líneas rojas una alusión
muy poco sutil a eeuu